it was strange i was pulling up to my
university or through college and i
would pull up and uh at some i would
pull up in like a drop top lexus like 70
000 car and i was like 19 right
[Music]
dude so um val sean uh he's not making
it today but that's okay we um
so
your thing
went viral today how many likes did you
get like three
thousand thirty three something like
that i had to turn off my notifications
i can't do when you work with i don't
know how you guys do it i don't know how
people do it while running full
businesses but um i had to turn that off
because i just can't concentrate that
that thing just my phone was just
blowing up all day
now you know how i feel it is crazy
right it's crazy so you you had 3 000
followers and now you have like nine
maybe nine thousand something like that
yeah i mean it took me how many years to
get up to like 20
700. um
yeah now it's i don't know i didn't look
to be honest with you but i'm probably
at like eight nine thousand at this
point
so all right the background here is i
met you through
my like we we share like a best friend
joe
and
we joe told me about you he goes this
guy's crazy and so lit val let me tell
you what i know about you and you tell
me if it's right or wrong and then i
want to hear your story but basic
basically you he goes
and i'll i won't reveal too many numbers
i'll let you talk about any number that
you want to talk about because i don't
know if what i know is confidential or
not so i'm not going to i'm not going to
mention them but
you as a 19 year old you came from uh
russia you came from russia i came from
uzbekistan
it was about the age of 11
and then you come here you get a
computer at like 16 or 17 you start this
uh affiliate marketing uh business
you're the only employee by age like 22
23 you've made something like 30 million
in profit from this like one little
business from there you parlayed that
into in a
lyric website that was like one of the
biggest
lyric websites in the world which
doesn't sound that impressive but most
people don't realize that lyric websites
are some of the most
biggest websites in the world and so
that made like another eight figures in
profit from there you parlayed that into
an ad network that now is like huge from
there you've now launched a jewelry
business that apparently
joe has said it's bigger than all your
other companies but i don't know if
that's true or not and then throughout
all this you've acquired and sold and
developed like
a hundred plus million dollars of real
estate is all this accurate uh some of
it uh okay so
well actually my first and by the way
the reason i'm having you on here is
because we've had a lot of really
successful people on here do interesting
stuff and there are like a lot of them
are well known but you
don't i basically the other day begged
you to like tweet something and i helped
you write this tweet and it took like a
few days and we got it out there but
like besides that you pretty much have
never done any press you've never talked
about this publicly and when i met you i
was like this is a gold mine this guy
has so many interesting stories we gotta
tell this story so anyway what was wrong
and what was right
so okay so well actually the funny part
is that the the first business i had was
a playstation like a video game website
so
it wasn't like huge but you know i was
in high school and making like 5 000
bucks a month
that actually taught me a lot of lessons
um so the so the
the search market and you actually told
me i actually tweeted another thing
about you where you said hey my 12 year
old son has a website that's making like
two g's a day or something like that um
and he needs an email service provider
which one should he use and i tweeted
that screenshot and it would be yeah
well that was anonymous i guess it's not
anonymous anymore but uh
so he he's uh yeah that that is
interesting i saw you post that um and
he still has a website it's not doing as
well but uh
not quite at 2000
um
anymore but uh he's uh he's working on
like coding this thing away and he's
like figuring out all these things so
it's actually amazing to see it you know
at his age that you know so where'd you
get
it's crazy that you and your family you
just find all these opportunities where
did it start so you your thing first
thing was a playstation website which
what is that
so a site called psx extreme
um we this is like i launched like 98.99
or something like that actually 99 it
was right before the
the bubble the dot com bubble burst i
was like about
eight months into the the the bubble and
it was doing really well it was very
easy to generate revenue and you know
once i got the traffic it was the site
was all about
anything related to playstation
so like get cheat codes your reviews
um screenshots whatever right anything
for like playstation fans so it was like
a playstation fan website
then the dot com bubble hits
my revenues disappeared 90
my traffic was still up there but i had
no revenues because all the ad revenue
disappeared like it went from being
three dollars cpm down to 30 cents cpm
if you could be lucky enough to get that
how many people were going to this
website um it wasn't huge but i had like
like ten thousand uniques a day
maybe twenty thousand and ninety 99 and
98 that's got to be a massive site yeah
it was good it was a good amount of
traffic and it was all free
um
so it was interesting like experience
because i had to quickly learn how to
generate revenue and i i had to go out
there and sell advertising myself
and you know like i and then once i
figured out that i could sell
advertising
i didn't have enough traffic
so i went i started going to other video
game sites and saying who had much more
traffic than me and say hey i got all
these advertisers who would spend more
if i had more traffic like i'll let me
put ads on your sites
so i went to all these other
video game sites
and like just
was a broker for advertising so that was
kind of like my first uh you know
making decent amount of money um i was
making five and like just from the site
and i was making probably another 10 a
month
from being a broker
and then the thing that you tweeted
today
or maybe last night it basically you
told the story about how when you were
19 after this playstation site you built
an affiliate ad site and it made like i
forget the i forget the numbers but in
two or three years it was like over 30
million in profit so what were you you
were selling stuff on behalf of half.com
or ebay who were you or no new york
times you had like 800 basic you
basically you had like 800 ad accounts
that sold different
stuff so like a new york time
subscription for
which sold for a hundred dollars but you
were able to uh sell it for only 30
bucks so you were able to keep the
difference something like that yeah so
you know it's affiliate marketing but i
use page search
which was very new back then
and at the time
um
when after dot com
bubble burst all the advertisers
got all sudden advertising digital
advertising stopped being interesting
you know for a sec for for a moment
there people thought businesses thought
it might you know internet might be
over
right
so all of a sudden you see kind of all
these budgets get you know just get
pulled back
right especially all the brand
advertising and
but nobody really you know so everybody
has to still figure out how to get
customers so they say okay you know what
we won't do brand advertising
but if you dr if somebody drives as
customers we'll pay per customer like we
can't loosen that right so performance
marketing
um so that was around and it was very
um accessible
and at the same time
the media wasn't expensive
right because the supply was there but
the demand wasn't there so that's what i
took advantage of
i started buying up a lot of supply
mostly was search search page search and
that's what made everything so uh
profitable because i was just playing
into those supply demand dynamics that
were working in my favor
um
but yes what i would do is i would find
an advertiser
that had a product
i would test it on
at the time you know kind of like the
the modern day yahoo paid search or back
then was called goto.com
and then later google came around
and so i would test that ad if it works
i expand on it if it doesn't work right
i would figure out how to make it work
right uh if there's a if there is a
if there's a way to make it work
and yeah just like
it just uh you know i was like
and what what things are you saying oh
man everything everything um yeah and
all this and all this was making like
uh like
many millions of dollars of sales for
your little one-person operation every
year
yes
that's crazy about yeah tell us a little
bit about like what was going on in your
life at the time like did you try and go
to college were you doing this while you
were at college did you drop out like
what are you doing with your life uh
so um
i already had the business um
and
i went i got into
like i'll have finance so i was like all
right so i'm gonna do business finance
and i didn't really feel like i should
be but i only did it because and i had
no time for it
you seemed like you'd be awful at that i
am i was awful i was actually interested
in the topics especially the topics i
was interested in like
law or finance or business accounting
all those things were interesting like i
couldn't i couldn't sit through biology
but even even though they were
interesting i had no time to study so i
would suck the tests my gpa was horrible
i can't remember what it was but it was
just horrible um
because i just didn't care to
you know get prepared for the test
i slept in
half the class of just catching up on
sleep because i would go to sleep at 4
o'clock in the morning and then
don't you don't you still do that don't
you go to sleep at four and get up at
noon
yeah i average four or five
yeah so if i go to sleep
i think yesterday i wanted to be four
three i woke up at 11 so i try to get
try to get seven hours of sleep it
doesn't happen all the time you know a
lot of times i have to you know live on
five six hours
but do you
do do you recognize that you're a weirdo
um i'm used to i'm used to it you know
what i'm i'm a weirdo
um
i i know i'm i'm do i do everything in
reverse my wife keeps telling me like
like you do everything backwards
so
you're you're studying uh finance but
you're not doing well because you're
running these businesses well i'm in
school just because i have a jewish
mother and she
wanted me to go to like you gotta be in
school you have to be in college right
or you have to go but did they know that
you're like hey mom like i bet you i'm
making more money than you
uh i i think she she kind of knew i
don't know if she knew but uh what i was
making i don't remember um
but it was it was strange i was pulling
up to my university or through college i
went to baruch um um new york city
baruch
business of uh finance ziklin business
of finance
um and i would pull up and uh at some i
would pull up in like a drop top lexus
like a 70 000 car and i was like 19
right so or 18 whatever i was i think it
was 18 at that point i think i don't
think i even started the
paid surgery at this point
so this business is just like crushing
it so like a few years in you've in your
tweet you said it made over 30 million
in profits like three four five years in
so it's gone really well you're paying
like a crazy amount of taxes you said so
you decide to move uh to the burbs a
little bit outside of new york city and
you like buy a cheap house in cash so
things are going well right like it's
but you you
said
you know i'm a little bored with this or
i don't really want to go much further
into this in this racket i want to try
something new and then the next business
was uh mobilefuse which is around today
right
um so i actually launched around the
same time
um we launched two businesses so after
han so i
i launched i launched the let's call the
the the music content distribution
company oh that's right sorry right so
that
so we didn't own i didn't own actually
lyric sites what i did is i built a
service
uh i built a system that
connects
called ringtone matcher
and what i realized was there was demand
for
ringtones and there was all this traffic
um for all this music related traffic
especially in lyrics
and so what i did is i built a service
and the other thing i realized that the
traffic was very much international
like 70 of of a music site or lyric site
was non-us
and i noticed that some of the
advertisers like ringtone advertisers
were advertised they'll do okay
but they would have only uh they could
only accept u.s customers and they could
only accept like verizon customer only
t-mobile customer
so i built this thing called ringtone
matcher and
ringtone matcher basically integrated
like
countries into one
system
so if you have a music site
you could drive
that those users to ringtone matcher and
ringtone match will figure out
based on geo like what country you're in
right
based on what carrier you use because
it's carrier billing so it's important
that you know i figured out like ufc
mobile
and
to match you up to a ringtone service
that actually um
is compatible with t-mobile
and then the third thing we look for
that content is available so if you're
clicking on hey get this
get toxic by britney spears ringtone on
your phone
i need to make sure that
that song is also available in their
catalog
because some
some ringtone providers had um
like warner music and some of some of
them maybe just had the emi they were
like four major music companies at the
time
and uh you know these ringtone providers
didn't have all those catalogs so they
might have one or two at a time so i
would take all that data
and put it into one simple
link
and and how big did that get
how big did that business go i was in a
front of ringtone matcher was in front
of a half a billion people a month
yeah half a billion so
um
and it was everywhere i mean it wasn't
just lyric sites i was on cbs radio aol
radio yahoo radio last fm like every
pretty much every music site
i remember even talking to musically
which is tik tok now right i remember
even talking to those guys i was talking
to
uh we were talking to whatsapp in the
early days like when they were just two
guys or something like we wanted to
integrate because anytime somebody
mentions music or a song or something
like i wanted to be i want my
i want to bring the matcher there to
show up so and but
but when you're you're using the word we
again it's not weird no this company was
so actually that company
i started ringtone matcher myself
again that was a one-man show
at some point i um
we
you know there was one little group of
guys who were pretty good at dealing
with advertisers
and or actually ringtone providers and i
felt like i need help on that front
and
so i merged those guys in so there were
five guys that merged into my company
um two formed when you say merge
who bought who
i was a majority owner of the company
and then the the five guys had
the like they they had a third of the
company i had two thirds
how big was it when it was just you
um it was just it was going nuts up but
uh
i think
i believe the the year
i think the year we merged
it was 10 million
just again just
10 million profit with just you
do you
why do you think so this is the
we'll get to the rest in a minute but
why do you think that you find this
weird stuff and why don't you hire
people two different questions but how
on earth do you find this type of stuff
you know
it's it's funny like i know i see how
organized you are right like you make
your goals you lay everything out on
paper right you're very organized then
you could think about it you ask people
for feedback um
i'm totally opposite of that
um i just kind of go with where like i
like to test things
and i'm i guess i'm very curious um
and uh and i and i i could be very very
focused but if i get distracted i get
very easily distracted right
so it could be like sometimes it's a
curse but sometimes it's a blessing
a lot of times it's a blessing um
and i come across these interesting
things and my curiosity just
takes it further
um so when i when i
so
the way i actually came across
this thing
was because i felt that there was a
point of my life where i was seeing
google was just too dominant part of my
business
and i didn't like that
um because i didn't want to rely on any
one thing
so i started looking outside of page
search
for supply
um
and i came across these music sites and
i actually started testing rhapsody on
them because i had such a good deal with
rhapsody i was like let me start
marketing outside of search
i did okay
and i had these you know i started
building these relationships with the
music sites and then then then i kind of
tested a ringtone service and it just
crushed like it was
not even close
like i did three times better and i was
like wow this thing did three times
better than rhapsody
and that
ringtone provider
was uh just covering us just like one or
two music labels
and like two carriers out of four i
think i had four there were four major
carriers at the time
i was like hold on a second if it's
already doing
three times as well
what happens if i start integrating
everything globally right
so that's how ringtone macho came about
was your when you launched stuff what's
your first version like
junk like you get the
idea it was a kitty script
i wrote
um
this you know guy was kind of
freelancing for me a little bit um i
just i didn't want to tell him about the
idea
he's actually a cto of one of my
companies now
um
he was like 15 16 years old
and i didn't tell him the idea so i said
hey how do you script this how do you
script that
so i scripted it myself
and um
and uh so yeah so it was pure junk it
was literally just a bunch of if and
then statements on and and asp
we were running windows um windows
server on asp
infrastructure so
i uh
i had a bunch of redirects that were
just doing a bunch of if and then
statements and redirecting people based
on certain parameters wouldn't
and when you're doing it are you like
see every time i've hung out with you
the reason i like hanging out with you
and joe i consider joe one of my best
friends and so i have like his attitude
you and joe have the same attitude which
is like
he's a little more laid back than just
and you i think
he is he is i've never seen him lose his
temper he is very calm and i'm like hey
this didn't work out for this reason he
goes oh that's okay like he's super calm
but you have that too i think i think
that like
i think that what it you have this like
i don't know if it the right word is
like hutzpah if the right word is like i
don't know what the word is but
it's almost like
things
i've heard we're going to get to the
rest of the stories because because
there's like this jewelry business that
you started which is like seems like
even bigger than
all the other things that you've done
potentially and
you like do these things where i'm like
but like val you don't know anything
about that and like you don't even have
any employees like you don't know
anything and but you just are like yeah
but uh you know
whatever i'll just we'll just go a
little bit further and then we'll see
what happens and then if it if it sucks
i'll bail you know what i mean like you
have this like oh shucks attitude like
oh you know yeah we'll see what happens
it's very interesting whereas like if i
was doing what you were doing and i
started seeing those results i'm like is
this illegal am i breaking the law am i
going to go to jail what is going on
like
oh it's almost like i would have most
people would have self-destructive
tendencies when they see this like going
so well yeah look i see that all the
time i feel like people
tend to overthink things and spend a lot
of time like analysis paralysis
and the reason i think a lot of people
are successful
like especially somebody like me
is
well somebody's thinking about
making perfecting one thing which by the
way will still have a you know 60
failure right and that one thing that
you just overthought
i rather test 10 things by within that
same time period
and i will likely have i have a better
um
accuracy or i'll have a better um chance
of hitting it out of the ballpark
with one of those 10 things maybe more
than one of those things
yeah how did you get into the jewelry
business to start with
um so after i sold
those two music related companies
um which
i took like three years off
off you know i thought i retired all
right um but it was anything but i just
got
started getting like
my curiosity was just taking me into all
different like
i was on all these boards and i was like
you know investing into a bunch of
things and
um and i realized that's the three years
i need to build something again
so i started looking at i knew that i
wanted to do something where it's
fixing or
disrupting a fragmented space
i didn't really want to go after like
corporate america um
i wanted to go after like mom and pops
that
when i say mom and pops it could be like
you know i'm taking like car dealerships
right they do tens of millions of
dollars it doesn't mean they're tiny
right so i wanted to go after something
like along those lines
um
and i had some investments in the
jewelry space i had some family in the
jewelry space it's a pretty tight-knit
community i just happened to be
i had some family that too that that
knows that that that business um
i actually worked
as a teenager i worked um
every weekend i worked in a you know in
a jewelry store
i knew how to fix like i knew how to fix
jewelry i mean i would sit on a bench
uh with a blowtorch at like 15 years old
uh because my cousin taught me it was my
it was a it was a family business
my
my aunt and uncle's business they had a
couple
jewelry stores
and um they taught me how to fix jewelry
and um
to you know so i knew the business a bit
from the retailer's perspective
it always seemed like a
very
weird way to do business i always had
questioned everything like they're doing
and
so so
um so the idea was hey like these
retailers um if we could integrate build
a platform
and services
and we could integrate into them and
this is a 300 billion dollar industry by
the way globally
which fragmented but controls is
actually bigger um independents are
bigger part of the business fine jewelry
than
the majors the chains
so i knew that again if i could build
distribution but i had to bring um then
there's a lot of power there
but i have to bring value and
that's where my
expertise and data and marketing digital
all that came into
fruition you know so we basically put
this thing together we integrate into
stores and help them grow help them
bring customers cut costs increase their
revenue
how much did you invest to start it
um
to start it
i don't i mean to start it i think we
started off a couple million
so you put two million dollars a video
in the beginning yeah how big is this
but you've done more i think you put
more in since how big is this going to
be i put in way more i mean at this
point i put in eight figures into this
business um
i think it's a multi-billion dollar
company in the future
for real you think it's a multi-billion
dollar company like to sell
yeah market cap i i believe that hey i
don't know if there's anybody big enough
to buy my company or this or this
company we actually have a lot of people
this time around it's no it's no longer
just val
we have a lot of employees
i i believe this company will be
if it's successful we could do what we
need to do and we could really help
all these retailers step up their game
um
i i don't think that there's really a
company in that space
that would be big enough to acquire us
so like well but are you are you the ceo
of that company
is that smart i mean that doesn't seem
like you're you're just you get up at 11
a.m and
like you go to bed at four how are you
the ceo of a company that could be a
billion dollar company
um
yeah i know a good question look um we
have
a great team
that is able to
execute how many people
um
it's hard to say we became pretty global
but you know our our offices outside of
us are not all um most they're not
employees right so they're so all all in
um if i have to talk about factories our
our tech teams our marketing teams are
um
we're probably talking about 70 people
at this point
wow and who's like but
you're not running the day-to-day of the
business oh hell yeah yeah 95 of the
time goes into this business
so then are you like talking with the
employees and things like that i mean
you're like running all hands meetings
and things like that yeah i'm not big on
meetings i'll be on you know to be
honest with you um but um
but uh i'm very accessible to all my
team i mean
everybody on my teams have access to me
i go into the office
in the city we actually had the
we were in the office june june 2020 i
mean we had
you know covet like every it was ghost
town in the city and we had to figure
out how to be in the office because it's
not an eco it's not just a digital ad
business that i could just operate from
from work from home right we had to have
people in the offices and uh
we did all kinds of things we we
we got cars to car um to to pull people
in
to the office but um but anyway we yeah
i'm i'm i'm there i'm i'm in the weeds
but it's not like you're kind of
downplaying it i invested in one of
their your properties we bought a
six plex in greenpoint i think i forget
well we essentially bought
land right we bought a house because
it's gonna be knocked down we're gonna
build a brand new
uh we're gonna ground up construction
it's gonna be uh like
a nice a nice condo building
yeah yeah yeah that's that's what i mean
but i didn't even look at the details i
was just like anything that val does i'm
part of but it's it's way bigger than
you're you're just saying like it's a
project i mean i think you've bought
like 100 million dollars with the real
estate right no i haven't i haven't
bought 100 million we have six projects
couple of them already completed third
one is
just about to be completed actually two
the first two were completed and
completely sold out uh the third one is
about to be completed and go on the
market um and then we have three other
projects and they are getting bigger and
bigger
um
the value of um the the
the combined sale value of value of
those projects
would be approaching 100 million dollars
do what do you what are you tinkering on
now what excites you now
what and and someone asked a good
question which is what is the uh
the equivalent of ringtones today
what's the equivalence of
like it's just crazy that it's just like
you're kind of like this like digital
cowboy you're just like this like one
guy in the wild west doing this [__]
with like no rules it's just i just
think it's hilarious that you are just a
pirate who's taking it to the extreme
where are the digital pirates at right
now
uh it has to be like tick-tock
um
what do you mean
it's
you know you look for like those spaces
that haven't been touched right
um
i guess people ask me i think i think
that's what you're saying like what's
what what can you what can be marketed
these days and how
to get that kind of scale
and i i don't it's hard because what
i've seen over over my career
is that
the windows of opportunity those white
spaces right
the windows windows are becoming shorter
and shorter and shorter every
iteration
right there was the paid search probably
lasted a good six years
after that
um
or around that same time there was
display
that probably lasted a little less and
then there was social media that that
window probably you know the arbitrage
window right yeah yeah that probably
lasted two three years at best
now you talk you know now you got like
instagram and tick tock and you got the
instagram reels um i mean those are
probably also one year windows of
opportunity if you could kind of catch
that lightning and build on it then you
got something but your your window and
it's all rooted in distribution which is
how do you get distribution quickly
and you're saying that you think that's
tick tock do you think that window is
still open um i i think if you have a
knack for
understanding how get virality or get
content then then
you have your own distribution if you
don't have that knack
you got to figure out how to work with
people that
have
that that access so
if there's one company
that could work with all the sampars
right all the podcasters
uh how much is that worth
like
we're using a platform here right now
right that is just smart they're they're
doing the right thing like they're
focusing on
guys like you who have all this access
but they're not selling anything right
they're just selling you a platform
if somebody could sell
figure out how to sell a product across
a
number of podcasts
that's worth a lot and you could sell
i'll move a lot of product and by the
way
it doesn't have to be podcasts what
about all the
tic tacs who are doing all those dances
right
i know um
i know like for one company they they
scale to like 80 million in sales
a few years ago
i'm not going to mention the name of it
but um
they scaled to like 80 million in sales
just on the back of youtube influencers
what was the product it was cosmetics
and they just cosmetics was that
cosmetics it was just like makeup or
something or lotion yeah yeah the
numbers were just insane
and um yeah it was just a long place
like it wasn't just big influencers
even the like thousands of mediocre uh
influencers or the smaller um ones
that just drove it
so stuff like that like
latch on to something that is big um
especially if you could uh
latch onto the like the long tail of it
because not not a lot of people look at
the long tail part of uh sure businesses
well
so one thing i wonder you know like this
thing that val talks about of
testing out
10 different things before the other guy
can put his pants on right like you're
you're building your
uh
perfect thing that's going to take you
six months before you even get to market
great i'm gonna test 10 things in that
time that sounds really nice but also
like
i guess i'll actually ask sam first then
i'll ask you val like what do you think
it is about val what do you think it is
about either his skill set or his
personality that allows him to do that
much testing where other people just
like can't figure that out apparently
the uh i think that
this is a common thread that i've seen i
i my buddy joe is just like this there's
this thing particularly i find it
amongst immigrants
or children of immigrants and maybe
because they've like experienced some
type of hardship where they're like
uh like dude i've experienced some crazy
[__] or my family has experiencing it
has experienced crazy [__] i have zero
fear and looking like a fool if that's
the worst if the worst that's gonna
happen is i'm gonna look stupid or lose
uh a tiny amount of money i'm okay with
that and i don't so i don't have any
fear about that
that's what that's what i think i've
noticed that's the trend i've noticed
amongst people like belle
look i think there's a
i think
that's i think there's a huge that's a
huge factor
and
one of the things i look at like i'm
raising kids now right
how do i make sure that
they
kind of because
they're not going to grow up the same
way i grew up right they're not going to
come out
the resources they have the access they
have it's very different from what i
grew up with
so what i think i realized is
the power the power is in
resourcefulness
okay
i was able to make a lot
or do a lot i should say whether it's
money or whatever it is right it doesn't
have to be just money it could be
whatever whatever it excites you right
but i was able to do a lot with very
little
but it's because i had no choice and i
had very little like we weren't poor
like you don't get i didn't come from
poverty or anything like that but
but again my parents couldn't afford a
computer for me for the first six years
of my life here right
um
so i i got to think like how do i
recreate that and
you can't really recreate that for your
kids but i figured okay i'm not you know
i'm not going to give my kids everything
on a silver platter
so
so you i mean you just talked about my
son like he is
uh
he he he's his dna is very like like
mine like he's way ahead of me because
he has all these tools like you know he
has a computer way
before me
i didn't buy him a computer
i
made him
save up the money i don't care how he
does it birthdays work whatever
during that time he researched all parts
and everything
i think at the age of like
seven or eight
he built a computer bought the parts by
himself he built a computer from scratch
by himself i didn't even help him
that's crazy so
he now built two computers like
and he taught himself how to code and
um
so i i suppress resources for my kids
systematically
not like i don't feed them like they're
they're they're they're very they're
they're doing just fine like they're big
groups
they live in a nice neighborhood but
i systematically
uh make sure that they're not given all
the resources because
that's how
you
naturally learn to become resourceful
what do you think it is yeah
fundamentally it's about doing
more with less essentially you're saying
yeah yeah but but it has to start from
day one
are you driven by money
yes and no
um i i
yes because it's uh it's it's uh it's
kind of like a score
right i i don't see your money
it's like a it's a number and a bank
account right like you don't it's not
like back in the days where you look you
know you you know it's not like we're
scrooge mcduck like you get to jump
through the
to the vault of cash right like i i
would watch it as a kid and i was like
wow i want to be that guy one day um
um
and um
but uh
no i think i think what i'm driven
really is by
just winning
and um
there is i think there is a bit of sense
in me of um
that
i'm one step from losing it all
you still feel that way
uh i feel like it's still possible i
think i think it's a i think it's like
an immigrant thing um
probably
by the way i feel exactly the same way i
was like in bed last night telling my
wife i was like i need to go like a
therapist or something i'm like i'm
freaking out we're gonna lose everything
this is all going away
i feel the exact i feel
like i
for a long time i like had a plan on
where i would go if i was homeless
like i still don't believe that in some
ways in a in a weird way kind of
excites you not about homeless but that
you got a chance to figure it out from
scratch again
it yeah because i like uh it does kind
of make me because when you have nothing
it's kind of fun to
play games because
it's just easier to bet sometimes
you can't bet as much but it's kind of
exciting to be like just like a hood rat
with nothing like which which i was
um it is kind of exciting but i get fear
of like the anxiety i i feel of losing
everything
like i
like i have so many spreadsheets that
map out like all right when the money
gets to this number then i gotta go and
panic and get a job and start like
ubering like i have like a plan for that
we um
the reason why i had you on and ben the
reason why i wanted to show you this guy
is
now it's he's hard to explain but i
wanted people to understand like a truly
unique and original thinker
and i don't you know i we you're gonna
have to come on again but like d do you
does it do you understand what i'm
saying but it's very original thinking
yeah and you you can see that just in
the way that like you've out
have attacked have tackled like a
a different set of problems than anyone
else i've ever talked to uh just like
i've never talked to someone who's like
yeah i tackled ringtones and then ad
networks and then peer-to-peer lending
and then the jewelry business
like i just think that kind of
belies how your mind functions
differently than other people do you do
you feel that way like do you feel that
you
just have unique perspective have you
met anyone that looks at the world the
way you do
and if you acknowledge that it's weird
because and you're saying that you
didn't you didn't actually realize it
was weird until i talked about you in
the podcast like half a year ago which
is weird because how old are you like 39
at 38 and you're now just realizing that
you're you're you're an oddball
um yeah so i i i didn't see myself that
way until
you did the whole expose with that show
on that on that one episode
um
that you didn't tell me about but uh
after our lunch
but um i know yeah by the way i i i told
joe i was like dude i'd never do that i
almost always ask for permission before
i talk about it but i just was too
excited and i forgot
um
it was i have a i have a story but i'll
tell you that after um on that but um so
to me like when you said like oh this
guy goes from this
industry to that industry he's like
jumping all over the place and he's you
know kind of successful or or successful
and
doing it this is like
crazy i was like
huh
i i never thought of myself that way
that but it makes sense like
i i don't know i keep jumping different
categories i guess again that curiosity
just kicks in and
and
and i just but i i go after it instead
of just what if you know i just kind of
go after it
but um
no i i i until now i really haven't
realized uh
that how odd that is uh but thank thank
you for
letting me know that i'm uh i'm really
strange
i just think that like there's just a
bunch of unique
there's just a bunch of unique things
about you and i think it's so cool when
i say weird and odd that's a really good
compliment by the way yeah listen i know
you well enough now to to know that's a
compliment
so so the funny story about
again before you i was pretty under
under the radar right like yeah you can
find stuff on you you have to really
look like nobody really put it out there
right
and
so then joe tells me like
you're gonna do they did podcast and
i didn't tell my wife
and then the podcast comes out i'm like
hey sarah um
um the the
the um
this guy did a podcast on me
she's like
and
who cares about a podcast
she's like you know but he's not talking
about me
who cares like what a couple hundred
people gonna listen i'm like apparently
this guy has like a million people
listening
she's like oh great um she's like did he
ask you permission i was like not really
so i don't really know what he's talking
about um
so he's like okay so the thing comes out
is like so we're listening to it
and
and he keeps saying val you're saying
val val val like never say uh right
never say my last name and then you and
sean go into like this tangent talking
about red pill and blue pill or whatever
so she's like and so we thought like it
said
val part is over right she's like okay
it wasn't so bad he never mentioned your
last name
how he's gonna figure out who's val
and then after you went off to a tangent
with about the pills
and you're like oh by the way i forgot
to mention his full name
let me smell it
let me spell it out for you
and you literally spelt my last name
so she's like i'm to kill this guy
oh she was bad yeah she was mad she's
she's very she's very she's very nice
everything i thought that everything we
said you could find publicly and we
didn't reveal anything like crazy and um
i try to only like i just read your
linkedin that's basically all i did yeah
you could find stuff but it's you know
it's one thing to the information to be
out there for somebody to look for it
um but it's another one
when you're on full blast right like and
it's being discovered
um so right now by audiences so
so that's all
new to me
i know i i felt like an [__] when
that happened i i'm normally always good
at that so like if someone if we're out
with friends and people talking about
stuff i'm like hey is this private or
not like they have to make sure they say
it's private around me
um
you're you're a nice guy so i'll let it
slide
yeah i blew up your spot and
yeah i that's something i remember the
day that happened i was like oh my god
joe i didn't even realize it because
sometimes when shawn and i were
recording i forget that it's a podcast i
just like it's just like friends talking
to one
and i forget i'm like oh my god i forgot
that was i just said that on air i can't
believe that
so that that was one of those examples
but um
dude this was awesome what do you think
ben this is this is pretty badass
this is great it's got me fired up to go
i know you're doing your airbnbs this
year sam that's kind of your thing
though right before this podcast he said
don't do it
oh really yeah i think i'm gonna do it
anyway but he i told him these two ideas
that i might work on and he basically
said uh
dude i was like should i work on going
hard on content should i work on this
job board idea or this airbnb thing he
goes
do content and i was like oh that's what
i don't want to do i said don't do it
now
well i didn't actually he literally sent
me his response like three minutes
before the podcast so i didn't entirely
read the i haven't read the whole his
whole reply but he's he's like the he's
like the the the land thing that's just
gonna bog you down that's what he said
yeah i think i i i i think something you
could do in the future but not now
i do feel inspired after hearing for
about and from val of like i need to be
trying more things like just taking more
swings and like putting more experiments
out there to see kind of what what lands
i like that yeah look at that throw
stuff against the wall like see what
sticks um
what's the worst but when you throw mo
when most people throw stuff against the
wall it's a half-ass attempt when you
throw stuff against the wall like
you spend money or you like you said
that when you were like when you didn't
have much you spent like six or seven
thousand dollars on ads to see if this x
thing could work whereas most people
will like like oh that's i lose a couple
hundred bucks i don't want to do that
it's like you you actually try but that
was an accident like like in that thread
that was an accident there were no
budget caps back then so i turned it on
i go to sleep and i woke up to a 6 000
span
yeah but you still did it i mean i get
just like most people just don't do
your your attempts are like good
so
when i was going to all these music
sites you know how i get their attention
i would go to a site and i would just
kind of through alexa or whatever i kind
of know how much traffic they have
and i knew these guys were outside the
country
and to get their attention
i would literally email them and say hey
i'll give you a hundred thousand dollars
so i give you fifty thousand dollars
i'll give you twenty thousand dollars
prepaid i'll wire it tomorrow
just so you could uh test my ringtone
matcher link
for seven days
if you don't like it it doesn't make you
enough money
take the link off we never talk again if
you if you like how much it generates
we'll sign you'll sign a contract
um and everybody signed a contract
because those two text links were
generating like five times like somebody
who was making like a like
there were sites that were making like
top sites for making like a hundred
thousand dollars a month
i would pay him four hundred thousand a
month
on top of that and and how many people
actually took you up and said all right
fine everybody and then i'll put yours
they all wanted the money first oh the
money
um
my success rate on that email was just
i mean who the heck is going to take
money like up front
i would be like
you know what i don't need you to do it
up front i'll give it a try just because
you're serious and you actually told the
story on pom's podcast because you like
you're like
bold but you have high integrity because
like i think there was a guy who you
owed a lot of money to because uh they
were a customer of your or they were a
vendor and you just had a bill that you
had to pay them and they like changed
their address or something and you're
like dude i can't find you i owe you 60
000 and you like held on to the 60 000
for like a long time and you just were
seeking them out everywhere like hey
where'd you go i need to pay you your
money yeah yeah it pays off like um
um
we because we had so many international
people
um
in the music business when the great
recession hidden there they were in all
these countries and uh where their their
banks a lot of them were banks were
located in weird areas uh we're we're
countries like cyprus and they would
literally tell us hey stop stop wiring
us money we we don't trust the bank
we're working with i got to get a new
bank account
like we held their money for
they told us to hold their money for
i mean we had millions in our bank
account that didn't belong to us and
all these sites basically told me told
me like i was kind of like their bank
for for a while because they didn't want
to get paid and they didn't they didn't
trust the bank um
it was phenomenal to me like i couldn't
understand that they they trust us trust
me with their money
um
uh for i mean it was i think some in
some cases up to a year we were holding
their money because he had nowhere to
send it
that's crazy dude this is a good
conversation i'm happy you came on this
is awesome
listen you're doing
i told you before i love your podcast
it's very um
it's very like
it's it's very like
layman terms right it's it's actually
takes a lot of intellect in my opinion
to dumb things down well thank you i
appreciate that it helps uh
yeah often times i wonder like i've a
lot of my friends are english as a
second language maybe uh
it's like i'm always amaze can you
imagine coming to another country we
don't speak the language at like 12 13
14 15 16 and then like just crushing it
i just so i think that's just like
amazing i've got a bunch of friends who
are esls and they'll they'll like i'll
help them write stuff because um
they're just a little rough and i'm like
dude how are you so badass i just i'm
amazed that you you're i'm just amazed
at some of these yeah
and you're one of those people
yeah well
like whether you're a cell like my
english is pretty good now but i still
can't yeah put
my thoughts together in a way that makes
it so interesting for people
to
understand and you know how to break
that down so like you know you you help
me with some of my so my you know one of
my you know pieces on that so that's
that's power
well thank you i appreciate you coming
on this is badass
listen i appreciate you guys having me
on
[Music]
you